ah
you just gave me
the killer is escaping
yup it's the duo you never knew you
needed
the killer is escaping
lizzo and sarah paulson team up to take
on the killer is escaping tick-tock
trend inspired by paulson's now iconic
line from ryan murphy's american horror
story asylum
he's escaping
the killer is escaping yes i do know i'm
a tick-tock trend the trend of people
using the sound as they do or see random
things has been going viral for months
now making it one of the biggest
tick-tock sounds of 2021
period with celebrities like lizzo
he's escaping
and billy eilish getting in on the fun
he's escaping
in a recent instagram live with her
american horror story co-star leslie
grossman sarah admitted to being in the
same boat that a lot of us are when it
comes to the trend
somebody's playing it to some music and
then i don't understand it which might
actually be the point the killer is
escaping
they have no connection to me they just
know that there's some weird chick
saying the killer is escaping now as far
as how lizzo and sarah came together for
this moment the killer is escaping
that's unclear but over the years et has
spoken to the 46 year old actress about
her time on american horror story and in
2015 she dished on if she ever pitched
creator ryan murphy any ideas for the
hit anthology series the only thing i
ever pitched to ryan was when i played
the twins i asked if i could have a
southern accent because i knew i was
going to be playing
such uh i was it was going to be very
difficult for me to do to be playing
two separate personalities sharing a
body that i thought i wanted something
very grounding and all of my family are
from the south and i said i would love
to have something that was really would
root me sort of to the to the story and
he went okay you can have southern
accent that's fine and so i mean it
didn't make any sense in terms of the
rest of the players it didn't i mean i
didn't have to have it but it was
helpful for me